[Applaudissements]
moi aussi si c'est le cas dans un magasin
un autre conseil pour ceux qui ne croiraient pas
un juste ce que je pouvais
laver qui fait attention je t'ai dans ta poche
Est-ce que cela a fait
paquet assis de l'onglet de recherche d'opinion orange
confus
commencer par color lady j'ai fait la jupe
au figuré sont toutes les données qui sont dans
sujets je mets une ligne
attends
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Oui
et puis toi
oui bien pour votre profession mais correct
puis te battre à mort dans le monde et ça
alors t'as la gueule tu vas réussir
maintenant c'est déjà un nom
[Applaudissements]
la copie d'urine pro mini mail devient